[Music]
a uh
a florida boy
a ten-year-old boy was cuffed and purple
why'd you say that for ten-year-old well
because i feel like some kid's gonna die
or something
nobody died yet nobody died yet
it's not all steve day yet
florida cops released a mug shot of this
ten-year-old boy that they cuffed and
perv blocked after he jokingly texted a
friend that he had bought for assault
rifles
and was going to potentially do a mass
school shooting i didn't even know that
someone's joking until they do it yeah
you got a 10 year old boy right here
like it was a prank bro tensions are hot
right now we thought there was a law
prohibiting like the release of like
miners for mug shots like i think
yeah you're right it's a cute mug shot
though that's why it's really cute but
maybe because it's florida oh yeah
because florida is one of the states
where they don't have they don't do cute
[ __ ] yeah
florida police released the mug shot of
the 10 year old boy they publicly
arrested
for allegedly threatening a mass
shooting at his elementary school jesus
christ lee county sheriff carmine
marceno who touts himself as florida's
law and order sheriff defended publicly
exposing the juvenile by saying a child
pulling a trigger equals the same
aftermath
daniel isaac marquez who is 10 years old
boy was arrested saturday and charged
with making a written threat to conduct
a mass shooting after sending a text
about patriot elements
his friends are a bunch of [ __ ] rats
aren't they yeah big time big time the
boy's alleged text read quote i scammed
my friend and then he included a google
image of money according to his arrest
report quote i bought this end quote he
added a few seconds later and included
an image of four assault rifles and then
he said get ready for water day
referencing a recent school sponsored
event in which students participate in
water activities like playing in
sprinklers
how did he get an assault rifle
it's florida it was a photo so he's just
[ __ ] around oh
so he didn't actually it was a photo he
took got a stock photo he like took
[ __ ] a photo of four assault rifles
like i bought this [ __ ] and some sort of
praying allegedly
were banned in the 1990s
rifles were banned in the 1990s
this kid doesn't know the ars are called
armalite [ __ ] this shit's so dumb
do people really think
15 star stands for assault rifle 15.
they do yes
really
yeah of course people think that i think
that [ __ ] you know i think that too so
what does ak stand for assault kaifal
assault killer that's a new type of gun
too alaska
dude you know what what happens when you
get the air 15 and you [ __ ] hold the
trigger down and you hold it point it up
it shoots one shot
but people don't know that yeah people
think like it's in the movies where you
go yeah i think everything's a rambo you
know why because it's it's spray-painted
and it looks crazy yeah i've seen lots
of vietnamese cats dying in the movies
to these guns okay i know what i'm
talking about hey no you're not you're
talking about m12
i think they're ns13
it was called the m16
that's the era
it's cool it's called an m12 i spoke
very clearly no you're right m16 m16
maybe ms6 is out i think he's working on
mi7 anyways
uh he described wobb's wads of cash and
get ready to commit a mass shooting uh
in his text every single threat is
considered real quote-unquote uh every
threat is real until you prove it not so
like they wanted to kind of set an
example obviously during the season at
which we end the season of america in
which many children die via guns all the
time and it was one of those kind of
like let's set an example because if
you're gonna even text a joke uh or a
fake threat you have to have a real
consequence regardless
you guys think like all right so
remember when child abuse used to be
legal where you could beat the [ __ ] out
of your kids and still legal in asia
right it's illegal here in the u.s right
but everyone used to do that everyone
used to beat the [ __ ] out of the kids we
all grew up
fear of our time in fear of our
tyrannical parents right but then
when once all this is kind of lifted the
kids aren't afraid of nothing no more
right so do you think now there's way
more of these bang bang boogies because
they're not afraid of no one in the
consequences not to correct you buddy
because this is your show but there is
child abuse
it's called
i'm taking away your games in your phone
no internet and that hurts no way
hurts a [ __ ] child right that's the
best he represents a lot of voices in
america best friend in the whole [ __ ]
world bud do you think emotional abuse
do you think today's kids uh if they had
to pick and their parents were like
either i turned the internet off or i
suck you in the face
soccer in the face yeah they would pick
sucked me in the face yeah
would you guys take sock in the face for
sure i would what if your dad was strong
as [ __ ] can you can you choose can you
be like what about mom francis in ghana
what's the internet
you know what i would do take a little
bit of cough syrup first all right go
ahead
a little benadryl just to make sure he
doesn't cough after he gets punched
that's not why
dude i would get i would i would love to
i would get curb stomped to keep my
nintendo in the 80s
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] bite the curve
american history [ __ ] yeah dude
i feel like there were nintendo
regular nes regulars yes i didn't
realize i was talking to a guy raised in
poverty
i was yeah i was supportive for the
future do you remember the japanese ones
where you had to [ __ ] shave the sides
so you could put the blow and then put
the top loading one
because you know the american you put
the top the mega one is like this yeah
the japanese ones you have to load it
from the top but you had to shave the
sides of the [ __ ] you're talking about
the family computer yeah playstation no
nintendo because you had the japanese
ones uh blow the top you gotta shave it
after you finish shaving it you'll blow
the top do you guys have a dream casper
talking about it
yeah i had your guests yeah dreamcast
i've been working with this whole
[ __ ] day bro i like how they had
really seven games and then they're like
yo we're done
that was a rich kid machine
because you could have your memory of
your character or whatever and then you
could go to the arcade and and do that
remember dude gauntlet bro you play
gauntlet oh yeah wait you could do that
yeah
put a little password in you were
stabbing each other for wheeze when they
first came out
what yeah that happens every
my cousin used to work at a best buy
when that happened she was one of the
people who got to reserve one i guess
like they because there wasn't a system
in place where it's like oh you gotta
sell it to the customers people would
like hide them in the back and then
bring them out before their shift or
after their shift and she was saying
there's so many fights people are
following other people to their cars
like trying to steal them kind of like
how the sneaker game was for a while
right two dollars because like all for a
week
i did a troll video where i um it was
like it was like launch night for xbox
whatever the [ __ ] it is
new ones yeah xbox 360. yeah one xbox
one and then um
i i went i showed up at like 2 30 in the
afternoon when everyone's lining up
right so there's like 30 people tonight
and i and i show up there and i'm like
stand in line and then i'm like acting
all agitated and i'm like i'm like i'm
like can you see my spot and the guy's
like yeah sure i'm like cool i'll be
back and then
i come back at 10 30 at night
[Music]
and the line's like down on the [ __ ]
goddamn block right and i go to this i
go i go like excuse me excuse me excuse
me i'm like walking all the way through
the line and i go up to that same guy
and i'm like hey dude thanks for saying
my spot dude
he lets you in it's like dude it's like
15 minutes before they opened the door
and he's like
yeah yeah no problem like but
technically he said to your spot
absolutely not cheap yeah yeah yeah no
but so this is oh no this is 10 30 so
then it's not going to midnight and then
i'm standing there and i'm like hey it's
[ __ ] cold you know it's cold oh my
god it's [ __ ] cool and i'm like oh
man i'm going to go home take a shower
and i'm just going to put a blanket on
real quick and i'll be like i'll be
right back can you see that's why he's
like
and then i go excuse excuse me all the
way out
and then i i was going to come back
again but it started raining and so they
had to let everyone in so i didn't get
to do the prestige oh [ __ ]
dude you know what the craziest thing at
the at the el salvador um
uh airport they were selling a ps5 there
for a thousand dollars what in the
airport geez why just well psy's are
selling for that much in general yeah
you're not getting a retail price and
you're getting a second market which is
almost everywhere because literally
there's like websites blogs twitter
followers that are just dedicated to
scouting out ps5 when they become
available in stock at walmart best buy
target whatever i researched this [ __ ]
when i had kovid which because i was
like [ __ ] it i'm gonna get a ps5 and i
finally got one after like checking like
blogs and stuff was it worth it
for me yeah
is it a back of the truck deal
for me yeah was it a back of the truck
no idea how sick it is to [ __ ] not
have like loading screens for certain
ps4 games i just feel like your reaction
didn't warrant like uh it was worth it
yeah and you worked so hard to get it on
screens i don't give a [ __ ] dude you
know how many ads i have to watch all
the [ __ ] knives i have no [ __ ]
respect you guys coming here [ __ ]
playing my [ __ ] video games oh
goddamn time you got no [ __ ] turn it
on anymore no all of you die in
miserable death the way we actually play
that is all four of us sit on the
joystick and maneuver
nowhere's like this who's the winner
usually oh yeah who's the most nimble we
just anal ourselves we just squat on it
and then we're hitting the [ __ ]
buttons like this what we're that's it
yeah is that okay fine motorcycles
we have lone suckers available no but
we're like oh yeah no oh is it the game
or does it feel we're not even turned
forward either we're just looking the
other way the first guy who comes loses
though
it's always me it's always there [ __ ]
next
and nick's always nick always picks chun
li which we all are like that's a little
gay yeah
come on but i'm really good with it and
then we're like okay let's go out over
our joysticks
i'm second today sagging hey dude he's
hey don't sleep on him
don't sleep on him
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]